for him unless he is detained and unless
he's overthrown and like
handed over by a successor regime it
means he can't travel because he might
be arrested
um and it may indeed encourage the
process at home of his replacement we
don't know very much if anything at
least people like me don't know anything
about what's going on in the Kremlin to
see his overturn uh and replacement but
there's enough information seeping out
to indicate that there are some who are
unhappy with his leadership and having
your leader labeled and treated as a
criminal throughout the world might just
be a bit of an encouragement to see
change of regime uh becoming more
palatable or appealing to those who
would like
trade to continue and develop
something to be decided about the assets
of their country that have been frozen
around the world and so on so he may be
handed over he may not he may disappear
into Russia if somebody else takes over
his life may come to an end
but in itself it's a very important
process and I'm grateful that Karen Khan
and his team have finally brought this
out interesting what you're saying there
as well that you think that this could
uh well be a catalyst it may embolden
those who are perhaps
um harboring some kind of desire to see
him overthrown yes I think it may do it
may have all sorts of other effects for
example there's a movement abroad
started by some Ukrainian
parliamentarians to relieve Russia of
its powers in the security Council now
those Powers have avoided have meant
that Mr Khan can't deal with the crime
of aggression
if the moves already being taken by
Ukrainian parliamentarians in their
advocacy around the world to for example
have Russia suspended from being
effective in the security Council
something to match what happened to
South Africa for 20 years under the
apartheid regime then that might free up
the potential for him to be
dealt with by the ICC for aggression as
well that would be extremely helpful so
far as your phone is concerned
uh just let me turn this off right
that's that's the Rival broadcaster I
think trying to get it no I don't think
it is actually it might be no I don't
think it is
um but
um so that's that's one thing that might
develop
uh and was the second thing but now my
mind's being interrupted so I forgot
what it was but that could be a very
significant development if uh Russia was
removed from the security Council oh yes
yes it could and there's another
important thing to bear in mind that for
Ukraine arguably the most important
thing to happen when the war when the
fighting ends and assuming that uh
Ukraine is indeed on The Winning Side is
what's going to happen to the funds that
are Frozen now lawyers will tell you
um rise from all around the world will
tell you that their respective countries
that have frozen assets of Russia may
find it more difficult in law to seize
them and hand them over to Ukraine which
really needs those assets to rebuild to
rebuild uh its infrastructure we need to
rebuild its country now again each move
towards criminalizing or saying that
Russia is indeed criminal not to
criminalize it to say it is Criminal may
ease the process perhaps by relying on
United Nations resolutions and matters
of that sort might make it much easier
to free up those countries that need
political will to say well we've not go
seize the money but we've actually sorry
we've not just Frozen the money we've
seized it and Ukraine here it is use it
so that could be another great step
forward and for those of us who are
often unhappy and uncertain about the
development of the international
criminal law because
uh in practice it is often slow and
partial and so on and so forth this
really is a very very constructive and
positive move now this is of course has
been breaking and used while we've been
on air and neither of us have had the
chance to read all of the detail
um quite specific
charges isn't it about the deportation
of children you thought there was
something else in there as well
um many of the international bodies been
calling for the crime the war crime of
aggression now this is quite different
it's very specific
um what are your thoughts on why it's
that aspect that he has been charged
with well he hasn't been charged with
that because he can't be charged by that
because for technical reasons although
Ukraine uh afforded the ICC jurisdiction
over the war
um you can't try Russia at the moment
without a United without a security
Council resolution you can't have Russia
Tried by the IC uh investigated and
tried by the ICC for the crime of
aggression that's why I suggested that
um this whole business of the arrest
warrant
might help those who want to see the
removal of or the suspension of Russia's
veto powers in the security Council and
that would then enable the crime of
aggression to be investigated and tried
you may know and your viewers may know
that there's already an independent
uh a tribunal into aggression proposed
by Ukraine and with support from quite a
number of bodies and governments and
parliaments around the world now that
may be quite a good idea in itself but
it's adding a layer of complexity
nothing would be better than for the
existing powers of the ICC to
investigate and try aggression to be
released as they could be if uh Russia
is itself relieved of its power to
exercise a veto and the security Council
do you think because of the specific uh
charge there about the deportation of
children we were hearing from
um Dominic wagon here in the studio
um it's some hundreds of thousands of
them allegedly been deported will it
make any a difference to them to their
fate because of this charge now being
out there
I don't think I can answer that I think
that's a a question for your political
and possibly Security Experts
um what I can say is that dealing with
children in the way that's alleged and
indeed shown in various programs
including your own I think
um that's a crime under both crimes
against humanity where something has to
be widespread and systematic and it's
probably shown to be widespread and
systematic and it could be a crime a a
straightforward regular Geneva
Convention War crime so
um I I can't say well it's likely to
happen in Russia I mean unhappily one
has to say it could go both ways I
suppose but that's not for me that's for
others to comment on
we really appreciate your time
particularly at such short notice to
come and talk to us so Jeffrey nice
thank you very much indeed
um we're going to bring in a Dominic
wagorn now
um Dominic I know you've been monitoring
various reaction to this breaking news
that's caught us all a little bit
um on the Hop um some reaction from the
Ukrainian prosecutor General yeah all
we've heard from the chief of the
Ukrainian presidential staff is that the
ICC arrest warrant for Putin is only the
beginning and the prosecutors are also
saying that they're encouraged by by
what's happened so for them it's it's
hugely significant and more than
symbolic although Russians Russia's
foreign Ministry spokeswoman Maria
zaharova has said very quickly after the
ICC announcement that as far as they're
concerned the decision to issue an
arrest warrant for Peterson has no
significance whatsoever so a predictable
reaction from Moscow and Keith quick to
say that they as far as they're
concerned this is just the beginning of
efforts to bring Vladimir Putin to
Justice interesting okay uh Dominic
thank you very much uh indeed don't go
far away because I'm sure we're going to
be bringing you back in shortly here for
now though I'm joined by the lawyer and
legal commentator Joshua Rosenberger
good afternoon to you that's Mr
Rosenberg are you surprised by this
it is surprising isn't it because it's
such a dramatic move by the ICC
prosecutor to actually issue an arrest
warrant for Vladimir Putin and also his
commissioner for children's rights who
works in his office
on this allegation of responsibility for
the war crime of unlawful deportation of
children and the unlawful transfer of
children from occupied areas of Ukraine
to the Russian Federation these are
dramatic crimes of course there is a
practicality
obviously Putin is not going to stand
trial unless he is arrested and he's not
going to be arrested while he remains
running Russia and presumably the same
applies to Maria levova belova his
commissioner for children's rights but
nevertheless it is a dramatic move and
it shows how the prosecutor of the
international criminal court has been
working to try to achieve this
um we know that a trial chamber at the
international criminal court in The
Hague considered warrants the
application of warrants in secret in
order to protect victims and Witnesses
and to safeguard the investigation and
it says mindful of the fact that the
conduct is allegedly ongoing and the
public awareness of the warrants May
contribute to the prevention of further
crimes
the Chamber of the Court considered it
was in the interest of Justice to allow
this to be disclosed the existence of
the warrants name of the suspects a
crime and and the related facts so we
have this slightly unusual
announcement the way the international
criminal court works is sometimes that
it has arrest warrants but doesn't tell
the suspects for obvious reasons he
doesn't want to take them off but on
this occasion yes we have got this
announcement and all the publicity that
goes with it and would you agree with
Sir Jeffrey nice that this effectively
raises the stakes for countries
um that have not been hostile to
President Putin in his regime
well it's interesting isn't it I mean
Putin is clearly going nowhere and so
there's no question of any uh country
that might support the international
criminal court carrying out this arrest
warrant uh but but yes it does raise the
stakes doesn't it it just reminds people
that there is law that the law is
imperfect international criminal law is
imperfect because the international
criminal court has no police force of
its own it relies on states to cooperate
with it
um and and as things stand nothing very
much is going to happen in the short
term but nevertheless it does show that
there is the possibility of criminal
charges something that Putin would have
been well aware of ever since he started
this he obviously thinks that uh this
this hasn't deterred what he's done over
the past year or so but yes it is a
significant move isn't it uh you know
here is the statement from the
prosecutor saying there are reasonable
grounds to believe that Mr Putin Bears
individual criminal responsibility for
these crimes for having committed these
acts directly jointly with others
there's failure to exercise control
properly over civilian and Military
subordinates who committed the act or
allowed for their commission and who
were under his effective Authority and
control and this is just one crime that
he's being sought for so yes this is the
beginning of what many people hope will
lead to international criminal justice
but clearly so long as he remains in
charge and so long as he remains in
Moscow nothing very much is going to
happen
could it though catalyze further
isolation of President Putin very
significant isolation I.E the removal of
Russia from the security Council
well that's a very interesting question
isn't it because uh the international
criminal court is not directly part of
the United Nations it is a separate body
set up by a number of states but on the
other hand it has close links with the
United Nations because the United
Nations can refer cases to the
international criminal court
um it's really a matter of the United
Nations I don't suppose the United
Nations needs to be told uh that what
Putin is doing is is breaking
international law uh is is breaking the
UN Charter
um and you might think that you know
unlawful deportation is a relatively
minor charge uh compared with you know
what Putin has been responsible for over
the past year or more but yes it does
show that that the tide is turning past
does it tell you though given uh you're
describing it there as a relatively
minor charge uh still very significant
isn't it for all of the families and
indeed the children who've been affected
by this does it tell us that the fact
that they've gone for that one is the
that it is the charge that they feel
they have the most evidence for
yes it does it shows it's the most
practical charge
um what we don't know is what other
charges are available what other charges
are being considered at the same time
um all we know is that they have chosen
to to bring this particular charge to
public attention at the moment
um you know the the there is I think you
were discussing with Jeffrey nice at the
broader question of the crime of
aggression uh but that's something that
will require an international agreement
in order that can that it would be
possible to to bring these charges this
is a practical charge which the
prosecutor has but evidence to the court
over which to cause is authorized an
arrest warrant for in which the
prosecutor believes he can take action
over subject as we keep saying to the
need to actually get Putin Behind Bars
to have him arrested which he's not
going to be at the moment but who knows
what's going to happen
um it it must give Comfort I would have
thought to ukrainians as you've been
reporting to the families of children
who've been allegedly deported
um and and as I said the whole point of
this is to try to put him on notice that
the more he carries on the more risk
there is of further charges or at least
charges relating to this particular
alleged War crime yeah I mean ukrainians
will note this as a significant move but
they will probably also be saying not
before time we've been asking for this
for months so Jeffrey nice was saying
there that perhaps the ICC has been
under external pressure not to do so
what what's your view
oh I don't think so I don't think so um
I think the um prosecutor of the ICC a
British QC Karim Khan a British Casey
Karim Khan a senior Barrister
um uh knows that this is the the making
of the international criminal court
um if he can
pursue charges against Putin and and put
Putin on trial this will justify uh the
decision of the International Community
to set up a permanent international
criminal court that could put
individuals on trial for war crimes I
think he has been trying extremely hard
to to do this he may well have thought
and there may be these these these
sealed arrest warrants these charges
which we haven't been told about
um uh they may all be lined up and he
may have good reasons for not making
them public but no I think he has been
working extremely hard together with
other members of the international
community supported by the United
Kingdom to gather evidence
and he has thought that this is the
right time now to actually announce uh
these these these arrest warrants
um and to to pursue Putin and and this
uh the commissioner for children's
rights in his office so I I don't think
that uh he's been dragging his feet but
I do think he's well aware that you know
that he doesn't want the international
criminal court to look powerless and it
is powerless so long as Putin remains in
charge in Russia yeah um we've been
talking a little bit about legally what
might flow from this so Jeffrey nice was
saying that perhaps
um once there is an acknowledgment of
war crimes being committed that that
could help with the frozen assets to
then give them to Ukraine in order for
them to start to rebuild their country
eventually
that would be very desirable wouldn't it
but we we are talking about separate
criminal processes you know this is one
Court which is seeking to put him on
trial uh for which purpose he has to be
arrested and then there has to be a
trial and any trial
um is is is is is clearly months years
off even after he's arrested and then
there's a question of punishment so I
think it's probably separate from assets
and and what relates to it I mean the
powers of the Criminal Court the
international criminal court
um are to send people to prison uh
prisons places are provided by uh
supporters of the international criminal
court including the United Kingdom I'm
not sure that it's actually going to you
know have a direct effect on the conduct
of the war on assets on anything like
that but
um it is is it it's clearly you know a
sign that the international legal order
is determined to do what it can
to try to bring Putin to Justice
all right uh Joshua Rosenberg thank you
very much indeed for joining us again
also at a very short notice some news
which has taken uh many people by
surprise that is that the international
criminal court has issued an arrest
warrant for President Vladimir Putin now
we will be looking into what that means
and all of the relevant legal
implications of that at the top of the
hour which is now if you are joining us
it is four o'clock you are watching Sky
News the developing story at this hour
the international criminal court has
issued an arrest warrant for Russia's
President Vladimir Putin it accuses him
of being responsible for war crimes
committed in Ukraine an arrest warrant
has also been issued for Russia's
children's rights commissioner that is
for unlawful deportation of Ukrainian
children the ICC has released this video
statement within the last hour
the international criminal court has
issued Two Worlds of arrest in the
Eucharist tuition
for Vladimir Putin president of the
Russian Federation and foreign
commissioner of the Russian president
from children's right for the alleged
war crimes of deportation of children
from Ukrainian occupied territories into
the Russia Federation
it is forbidden by international law for
occupied powers to transfer civilians
from the territory they live in to other
territories children enjoy special
protection under the Geneva Convention
the contents of the worlds are secret in
order to protect victims the ICC
attaches great importance to the
protection of victims especially
children
nevertheless the judges of the chamber
and dealing with this case decided to
make the existence of the world's public
in the entrance of justice and to
prevent the commission of future crimes
this is an important moment in the
process of Justice before the ICC the
judges have reviewed the information and
evidence submitted by the prosecutor and
determined that there are credible
allegations against these persons for
the alleged crimes
the ICC is doing its part of work
as a court of law the judges issued
arrest warrants the execution depends on
International cooperation
well that was the president of the ICC
there announcing that arrests weren't
for President Vladimir Putin while
Russia has responded to the warrant for
President Putin's arrest it is as you
might expect the Russian foreign
Ministry spokesperson Maria zaharova has
said the decisions of the international
criminal court have no meaning for our
country including from a legal point of
view Russia is not a party to the Rome
statute of the international criminal
court and bears no obligations under it
well let's bring in our International
Affairs editor Dominic waghorn we also
have here in the studio retired Air Vice
Marshall Sean Bell uh Dominic to you
first a pretty predictable response
there from the Russian spokesperson what
in practice does this mean
good question I mean let's get some
reaction also from the ukrainians which
is important if we're going to quote the
Russians let's certainly quote the
ukrainians the prosecutor General in
Kiev Andrei kostin has said the decision
by the ICC was historic for Ukraine and
the entire international law system and
Andrew yermack the chief of the
presidential staff says the the warranty
is only the beginning and of course
ukrainians are building a whole dossi a
number of dossiers of evidence against
the Russians to deal with atrocities and
butcher atrocities to do with
deportations and particularly to do with
children so they will be sending that to
the ICC no doubt what's what's
interesting about this I think is the
ICC is focusing on this issue of very
troubling issue of what's happening to
Ukrainian children as Stuart was saying
in in uh Delete Pro earlier the figures
vary I think one respected independent
study claims that 6 000 Ukrainian
children have been deported so taken
from Ukraine under various circumstances
deported into Russia and then there is
on state Russian State media there is
this visual visible evidence of them
being handed doubt at Railway stations
to families adopting them but beyond
that we don't really know what's
happening to these children now the
ukrainians say that the figure is more
like 14 or 16 000 the Russians
themselves have said since 2014 700 000
children have been deported with their
families now they're saying that many of
them have gone willingly so there's a
huge question mark about the fate of
these children and I think it's really
interesting the ICC is focusing on that
highlighting that issue and of course
it's going to have implications I think
it is it's symbolic in the sense that
Putin won't be brought to Justice
anytime soon but this makes him even
more of a of a pariah there's now an
arrest warrant out for the leader of
Russia and I think it will make those
Nations who sat on the fence so far
who've hedged their bets those countries
and there are a number of them India a
number of African countries
um countries close to Russia who have
abstained in votes at the UN about
Russia being called on to withdraw its
forces from Ukraine the stakes are now
much higher position thematically now
some of those countries have done so
because they're worried about the
hedging the bats literally because they
don't know who's going to win Kazakhstan
for instance does not want to blot its
copy book in in Moscow if Russia wins
this war some way or another but I think
a lot of it has been motivated by a kind
of a moral ambiguity I think a doubt
about NATO's case and the doubt about
Ukraine's case and some of them have
bought Russia's line that this is all
about NATO expansion and just
self-defense so I think um it obviously
plays into that and it will make it
harder for those countries to abstain
and give support to Russia not just
diplomatically but by abstaining but
also behind the scenes buying Russian
oil so I think it puts pressure on those
countries and I think that's probably
the most likely way this has a material
impact on the conflict let's bring you
in here Sean are there any military
implications from this announcement I
think one of the concerns is how does
this conflict eventually get brought to
an end after Putin invaded Ukraine
hundreds of thousands of live been lost
the Russian military have not performed
well on the battlefields and so I think
the International Community is trying to
find a way to give Putin an off-ramp in
other words how would you call an end to
this brutality because otherwise it'll
just perpetuate anything that further
isolates Putin's position has a risk
that it risks him literally just
doubling down and focusing his
determination to continue this conflict
I think what's interesting for me on the
United Nations 141 countries uh damned
his invasion tried to get him to reverse
it or at least withdraw his forces it
was water off the duck's back to Putin
what matters to Putin is he drawn to
power from Russia itself yet he
absolutely controls the information flow
into the country itself and it doesn't
seem to me this is going to help bring
the war to an end anytime soon but
that's purely from a military
perspective and is your sense that this
might heighten the aggression coming
from Putin it's difficult to tell what
impact it would have in the future but
um if if President Putin saw a way of
bringing this war to an end and there
was lots of diplomatic language about
how he might be willing to start to talk
whether as long as he could screw the
Dom Crimea that maybe he'd be open to
negotiation if he knows that when that's
finished he's going to be in front of an
international criminal court it's hard
to see him beginning rushed to bring
this conflict to a conclusion and most
military analysts think that actually
his Ambitions lie well beyond the
donbass and Crimea almost certainly to
the full extent of Ukraine and
potentially beyond that more to the
former Soviet Union and I think that's
really worrying in the long term and
it's not saying that this since diamond
is wrong it's just trying to see how
this helps get bring this conflict to a
war a conflict to an end earlier because
the brutality the hundreds of thousands
of lives have been lost there's got to
be a compromise eventually to bring this
to an end and how that happens is a
primary focus from a military analyst
perspective okay all right gentlemen
don't go far away because we'll be
needing to bring in your analysis as we
move on throughout the afternoon but for
now let's bring in our U.S correspondent
who joins us now from Washington hello
there to you Mark
um a surprise announcement for many what
does the U.S reaction likely to be
oh well we can talk about it as likely
to be there hasn't been any official U.S
reaction at the moment but President
Biden does have a specific person an
ambassador at large as she's known uh
who is whose task from a U.S perspective
uh for many months now has been uh to
pursue Vladimir Putin along with uh
European British and other
um uh criminal justice systems to to
bring him uh to a courtroom and and I
spoke to her a couple of weeks ago and
the first I guess most obvious question
I asked her was was how obvious How
likely it is it would be that that man
there President Putin would ever be in a
courtroom and
her response was interesting she said
look we've got to play the long game um
there is no expectation that this man
would would be arrested at any time soon
but then she pointed out to to to
history Augusto piniche Slobodan
milosevic and the leader habre of Chad
all of those people never thought that
they would face Justice many around the
world thought they wouldn't face Justice
yet they did and I think that is the
driver for people like Ambassador van
Shack who I'm talking about uh the
President Biden's representative in this
Arena she described the various avenues
that she and others are are pursuing to
try and bring not just Putin but all of
those around him a joining the dots is
how she described it from from low-level
commanders on the ground in Ukraine
joining those dots and providing
evidence that join those dots that lead
right to the top uh to the Kremlin and
she said she described one Avenue as
being the prosecutor General in Ukraine
investigating these cases in their own
domestic Ukrainian court system that is
ongoing and the UK the European Union
and others are helping with helping
Ukraine with that matter the Second
Avenue is the one that we're focused on
now and that is the international
criminal court
um which has been as we say for many
months been looking into material
evidence against the Russian Federation
against Vladimir Putin uh so much
evidence I was struck one thing that she
said to me that because of the digital
world that we live in there is so much
digital evidence that they are having to
to sift through to collate CCTV on on
people's doorsteps in towns and Villages
across Ukraine personal TV cameras have
all caught atrocities in towns like
butcher in urban outside Kiev they've
got all of that everyone has a mobile
phone and many of these atrocities have
been caught on on mobile phone as well
all of this is now in the hands of of
prosecutors in different countries and
as I say that they're trying to join the
dots to be able to prove that as
commander-in-chief Vladimir Putin was
ultimately responsible for this you've
been talking a bit too about this this
idea of of a crime of aggression that is
something that is very very important to
Vladimir zielinski he wants to to pursue
that particular crime uh which which is
is clearly another Avenue that they're
looking at and it's not that one uh
particular Avenue uh can can work on
there on its own there are many that can
work together
um it's worth saying too that the United
States has a complicated relationship
with the international criminal court
it's not a member
um of the court itself but it likes to
think uh that it that despite not being
a member it can help to pursue uh
justice for people um who need to be
brought to Justice there's an added
complication specifically on their crime
of aggression uh because the crime of
aggression could be pursued because uh
Russia invaded Ukraine uh well some
point back a few years to Iraq the long
shadow of Iraq exists still and there
have been some who have called for a
crime of aggression against the United
States for what it did in Iraq her
response to that is that this is uh
there is there is no equivalence uh
between the two but certainly from from
my conversation when this with her in
the state department a few weeks ago
it's so clear that on so many levels
behind the scenes quietly uh there are
people on the ground in Ukraine
collecting evidence all the time indeed
she is has been there recently herself
and they are building a case using all
these different Avenues
um to try and bring President Putin and
those around him right the way down to
Commander level as well bring them to
justice we wait for them to slip up she
says whether whether it's senior
commanders who who travel abroad uh on
using aliases if we've got the evidence
if we've got the names the photographs
we can arrest them and as Dominic was
saying if Vladimir Putin was to travel
to a country uh that is that's tied to
the ICC
um to that system then he too could be
arrested unlikely yes but uh it's a long
game she said
all right Mark thank you very much
indeed bringing us the perspective there
from the United States we await a formal
response from the White House we know
President Joe Biden is currently in
bilateral meeting with the Irish Prime
Minister Leo varadka
um Dominic let's bring you back in here
and we're talking about quite a specific
um walk the arrest warrant for quite a
specific War crime uh not just President
Vladimir Putin but also Russia's
children commissioner children's
commissioner as well uh wanted for
arrest there um she has responded Yes
Maria lavova bolova who has been a
notorious figure throughout the war
because of what she's done with children
now she has claimed to be saving
children she's adopted a number of
children herself and um she has been
seen on Russian State television weeping
with joy she's been claiming as she has
talked about the children she saved she
claims to have adopted 22 Ukrainian
orphans one of whom was interviewed in a
very creepy Russian State tv piece where
whether he was onto duress or not he
said how grateful he was to her for
being saved um and When Vladimir Putin
appeared recently in a stadium in Moscow
um a number of Ukrainian orphans were
brought onto the stage and amongst them
was a girl a 15 year old girl who was
abducted by Russian soldiers a week into
the conflict her parents were killed by
these soldiers she went missing and then
she reappeared in the stadium now the
Russians have been claiming and this is
really for propaganda I think for
domestic purposes that they are saving
these children from what they regarded
what they claim to regard as Nazi
controlled uh Ukraine and so it's we've
talked about how this conflict is sort
of it's a kind of Alice in Wonderland
Looking Through the Looking Glass kind
of where it's portrayed in Russia what
we what we see is abhorrent they are
celebrating so the the abduction and
deportation of children in their
thousands they say
um is an active Ovation saving these
children from nazi-controlled Ukraine so
in that context we can quote what she
has said which she says that in response
to the arrest warrant being issued for
her from the ICC she says it's great
that the ICC appreciated my work to help
children of this country so as far as
she's concerned or is claiming to be
concerned she is saving these children
and therefore in a very Twisted
perverted way really she's claiming that
she's getting credit from the ICC for
her work but I think this is obviously
makes a pariah of her as much as it does
of of the president and it focuses the
spotlight very clearly now on the
president being directly involved
allegedly in this war crime of abducting
children
all right thank you very much indeed
Dominic as I said before don't go far
away gentlemen because we are needing
your analysis uh as we unpick these
developments throughout the hour let's
bring in now Mary dejevski a foreign
affairs journalist and also columnist
for the independent uh good to see you
this afternoon uh Mary what do you make
of this announcement from the ICC
well I think you know we've heard an
awful lot of analysis from from the
other correspondence most of which I
absolutely agree with
um I think one of the things that's
coming out of Washington which is often
said about the Iraq War this is already
the most documented War probably in
history
um and ukrainians themselves Charities
foreign aid organizations there is
masses and masses of evidence and
Ukraine practically from the beginning
has seen it as a sort of Mission to
bring people to Justice and to document
what's going on in Ukraine and I think
this is a very important aspect
um when we look at the actual charge and
the fact that it's being made today and
that it's against ported not just his
sort of children's commissioner but but
against paulton in particular I think
it's very interesting that it's quite a
limited charge it's this child
deportation charge which is of course
not just limited it's also very emotive
around the world it will cross country
cross countries and cultures that this
is about children
so that's one thing to say second thing
to say is that of course when it's
looked from from Russia and I think
we've had the foreign Ministry spokesman
already saying this charge actually
means nothing
um because there is no way that
um any any action can be taken again
supporting
um it's purely hypothetical and that
plays into what Mark was saying about
um the United States and the UN and the
ICC playing a long game here
what do you think follows uh from this
what does it catalyze potentially
well I think one of the things that that
follows is that
um Putin who is already
um a pariah across the West
um this is not going to help and Russia
actually you know it it knows that it's
in very big PR trouble across the West
although it has if not allies then these
people who've been relatively neutral at
the UN but Russia generally doesn't like
um being being singled out
um for
um for as it were International
indiscretions of this kind by
International institutions so
um I think even as they belittle it it's
something that will actually hit home
but I also think that in a much much
wider perspective
um the fact that this has been announced
today maybe it's not connected maybe it
is connected it's the same day that it's
been announced that Xi Jinping is going
to Moscow and he's going to talk to
Putin among other things about China's
peace plan for Ukraine now I can imagine
that as seen from the Western World this
is not a welcome development
I see
um could this change the conversation do
you think between the Chinese president
and the Russian president
um I doubt it will because I suspect
that the um the attitude on both their
sides is going to be well you know the
international criminal court this is way
down the line and these charges are very
limited
um and you know I think uh as as Dominic
was was sort of saying that Russia could
Parry these charges because it could say
that
um the reason it was taking children
across the border was to rescue them to
save them from conditions in a war zone
so it's not completely cut and dried you
know what what we call deportation and
abduction is described in Russia as
saving and rescuing
um and you know it's uh you you can say
well this is a cynical way of looking at
it but that's not how a lot of Russians
will look at it all right Mary jajevski
uh thank you very much for talking to us
here on Sky News Now now the UN Security
Council does give a daily uh briefing
they have been asked a question
specifically about this development from
the ICC let's have a listen to the
response
you know that's a question for
speculation that's not something again
the president of the general assembly
his his boundaries if I can call him end
within the general assembly
um you know there's always issue about a
diplomat or a delegate or someone who
who might have trouble getting visas or
something like that that is for the
Secretariat that is not something that
the general assembly deals with so I
would ask you to perhaps ask stuff on
that very same question excellent
excellent
um
Pam if I can the other question that you
asked me was whether there is a meeting
would the president want to have a
meeting on this topic that's what you
had asked me for and so my response to
that would be as you know it's up to
member states to come forward and say
that they want a meeting on a specific
issue so obviously if a member state
says that they want to discuss this in
the general assembly I know that the
president would would do that
the president's door is always open
well let's bring a Dominic and Sean Bell
back in here
um Sean you were saying to me earlier
that as far as the war goes this
probably doesn't help bring it to some
kind of conclusion no and the problem is
here is that it's really difficult to
see how Wars like this come to an end
because they only weigh either one side
wins or the other side wins it's very
difficult to see how Rush can ever
actually win this war taking the whole
of Ukraine and subjugating it all seems
well beyond the reach of Russia likewise
Ukraine expelling every last Russian out
of every corner of the donbass and
Crimea again seems unlikely So
eventually both sides are going to have
to talk to do that they need to be able
to be ready to talk and ready to
compromise and I think that's going to
be increasingly difficult if Putin
doesn't see the off-ramp the other thing
I think is interesting about this is
that a lot of the discussion about this
legal issue is whether or not Russia
should be expelled from United Nations I
think what's fascinating about that the
foreign United Nations was the League of
Nations and the former Soviet Union was
expelled from that as a result of its
invasion of Finland the problem is the
reason the United Nations was formed the
reason the G7 the G20 all these
organizations is not because everybody
has to agree but the war should be the
last weapon of choice if you can't
negotiate talk compromise and the moment
you start throwing out Nations out of
that uh that sort of assembly you run a
grave of risk that Wars are becoming
more likely and it's a really difficult
Nuance point but I do think there's more
to this than just expelling Russia out
of United Nations somehow Russia's got
to be punished for this but also most
primarily from a legal throw from a
particularly for a military perspective
they've got to find a way of drawing
this war to a close because otherwise
the killing is going to continue
hundreds of thousands of innocent people
Millions have been relocated and that
from a military perspective needs to be
the primary focus
um Dominic I know that you have been
monitoring International reaction
perhaps you can bring us up to speed on
what other countries have been saying
and then also as well your perspective
on what it means for the conflict on the
ground in Ukraine yeah I mean we've had
a little bit of international reaction
not an awful lot so far the Czechs have
said that they welcome the decision the
Russians um have said that has no
significance whatsoever ukrainians
welcoming it as well and just to pick up
what Sean was saying I think we've said
throughout weren't we that no one can
afford to lose this war the NATO and the
West can't afford to lose because it
then gives a carp launch to any dictator
to invade another country and get away
with it Russia can't afford to lose or
Putin can't afford to lose it because he
is I mean in his Essence effectively a
gangster and gangsters can't lose they
then look weak and they're then
vulnerable he's even less able now to
lose because he's an indicted uh war
criminal and it makes it much more
complicated I think to head towards what
we have been expecting which is some
kind of diplomatically negotiated end so
this conflict which is how most
conflicts end I mean it's hard now to
imagine Putin and indicted war criminal
or a war criminal at least with an
arrest warrant out for him sitting
negotiating with ukrainians it's
certainly makes that harder to imagine
and one other Insight I think you know
if we look at Putin biographers what
they have noted about him and his
reaction to another dictator and his
fate Muammar Gaddafi the Libyan dictator
who was also indicted um by the ICC some
biographers claim that that Putin has
watched the tape of him being dragged
out of that Culvert in Tripoli and being
beaten to death over and over again
because he is so occupied with the idea
that could happen to him and that's
that's what's motivated him most about
suppressing any kind of public and
political opposition in Russia so now
he's joining the ranks of the likes of
ramadhafi that's going to focus his mind
but probably not to end this war but to
try it it doesn't give him a ladder that
he can climb down it makes the off-ramp
harder to imagine I think yeah
um my last contributor there Mary
dejevski is saying that perhaps want
what has catalyzed this announcement
from the ICC now is the uh the visit of
the Chinese president and to Russia I
think it's possible I think lawyers and
courts tend to operate on their own
timetable
um but I think if we're looking at what
China's reaction to this will be I think
it doesn't recognize the ICC it
certainly hasn't signed the treaty that
set up the ICC because at the heart of
the ICC is the principle of extra
territorial uh jurisprudence and the
Chinese are very much opposed the idea
that one country or one Court can
interfere in The Sovereign Affairs of
another now that hasn't stopped it
voting or abstaining on votes that have
condemned Russia for interfering
violently in the Affairs of another
country but that is a central principle
of of Chinese foreign policy so it
hasn't it hasn't signed up to the ICC
whether that that precludes it from
supporting this I don't know I think it
makes it more complicated for Xi Jinping
as he goes to Moscow I think it's
unlikely that kind of motivated the
court which I think would have been
operating more on a question and
question of what evidence it's gathered
and and whether it felt it was in the
right position to to issue this a
warrant at this time you were reflecting
the response from the Russian foreign
Ministry a short while ago very
predictable
response Russia does not this from the
Kremlin Russia does not recognize the
jurisdiction of the ICC any ICC
decisions are null and void for Russia
as you'd expect yes in the foreign
Ministry spokeswoman Maria saharova
who's a pretty feisty speaker and very
combative in her Daily Briefing she says
the Signet this event this warrant has
no significance whatsoever which is what
you'd expect you'd expect I think
Defiance from Moscow behind the scenes
though I think Putin will be worried by
this and worried about what it means for
his future and the way the war is going
to continue in the future all right
Dominic thank you uh Sean uh just on the
wires here I can see Commander of
Ukrainian Ground Forces so that Russian
forces are trying to break through
Ukrainian defenses in several directions
in an attempt to fully encircle the
small eastern city of Bachman which of
course we've been watching for months
and months haven't we how might what is
happening on the ground now in the days
ahead potentially change from a military
perspective as you say we've been
talking about back moot for seven months
and actually if you look at this from a
purely military perspective Russia's
been pushing hasn't been making great
progress been suffering huge casualties
and this is all part of a Russian
offensive which frankly from you should
do a little bit of offense gain some
momentum pause refresh your soldiers
replenish them and then go again they
should have stopped some time ago and
what's clearly behind this continuing
assault around back moot is political
pressure it's not a military competence
thing it's political pressure it's
trophyism
um but back moot isn't a military Target
it's become highly symbolic and
unfortunately it's become a gladiatorial
ego war between President zielinski and
President Putin and President Putin is
determined to keep making progress the
amazing tenacity of ukrainians to stand
firm you'll have seen that even Lloyd
Austin and the American Chief of Staff
of the military have been really Keen
for the
um ukrainians to preserve their hard and
War fight the map here for the battles
ahead
um and yet still now I mean um to the
east of the bakamukta river that's
Russian to the West is the ukrainians
the road you can just see heading out to
the bottom is the Escape Route the
Russians are now making progress across
that River uh and it's amazingly
historical defense but literally Ukraine
is the David to the Goliath of Russia
and Russia if Ukraine is going to mount
effective accounts which is what the
Wester weapons the tanks are all there
to do they must preserve some of their
hardened War Fighters but of course at
the moment Russia's paying a high price
for this and I think this announcement I
think will just Harden Putin's resolve
that he's going to keep pushing the
other thing you've been tracking uh for
us over the last few weeks is really the
infighting the tensions between
pragodian who's the head of the the
Wagner mercenary Fighters and also the
Russian military what does this arrest
warrant mean for how that Dynamic plays
out Putin probably thought a year ago he
is was utterly omnipotent now that he's
got this war under way there are little
cracks starting to appear he's
controlling the information space but
the families back in Russia now are
seeing their dead fathers their sons
their husbands coming back they are
seeing a price for this conflict
likewise prigozin who when the Russian
army hasn't performed well on the
battlefield but it goes in his convicts
have managed to make progress even
though they've suffered horrendous
casualties but Putin probably judged
that Russian society would care less
about convicts dying than they than
their husbands and their sons back at
home but that led to precautions
influence and power start to rise and he
was becoming very critical and openly so
of Putin that was a threat to Putin and
he's now been put to one side brigosin
is no longer allowed access to the
prisons to be able to recruit convicts
he's not being given the ammunition he
needs yet he's in one of the fiercest
fighting of the war all of which seems
to be be undermining and all of this is
Putin now the cracks are beginning to
show around him probably not crucial yet
but the cracks are starting to appear
interesting okay uh gentlemen uh stay
stay with us because we'll be coming
back to you uh shortly uh if you are
just joining us now on Sky News it has
just gone half uh gone past half past
four the news to bring you the breaking
news this hour the international
criminal court has issued an arrest
warrant for Russia's President Vladimir
Putin accusing him of being responsible
for war crimes committed in Ukraine an
arrest warrant has also been issued for
Russia's children's rights commissioner
for unlawful deportation of Ukrainian
children the ICC released this video
statement in the last hour
the international criminal court has
issued two warrants of arrest in the
Eucharist situation
for Vladimir Putin president of the
Russian Federation and formerial
vovabelova commissioner of the Russian
presidents from children's right for the
alleged war crimes of deportation of
children from Ukrainian occupied
territories entered the Russia
Federation
it is forbidden by international law for
occupied powers to transfer civilians
from the territory they live in to other
territories children enjoy special
protection under the Geneva Convention
the contents of the worlds are secret in
order to protect victims the ICC
attaches great importance to the
protection of victims especially
children
nevertheless the judges of The Chamber
are dealing with this case decided to
make the existence of the world's public
in the interests of justice and to
prevent the commission of future crimes
this is an important moment in the
process of Justice before the ICC the
judges have revealed the information and
evidence submitted by the prosecutor and
determined that there are credible
allegations against these persons for
the alleged crimes
the ICC is doing its part of work
as a court of law the judges issued
arrest warrants the execution depends on
International cooperation
well as you might predict Russia has
responded to that warrant for President
Putin's arrest a Russian foreign
Ministry spokesperson Maria zaharova has
said the decisions of the international
criminal court have no meaning for our
country including from a legal point of
view Russia is not a party to the Rome
statute of the international criminal
court and bears no obligations under it
meanwhile Ukraine has welcomed the
decision with the chief of the
presidential staff saying it's only the
beginning
well let's uh bring back in our
International Affairs editor Dominic
wagorn and also retired Air Base
Marshall uh Sean Bell with me now
um Dominic for viewers who are just
joining us so just summarize for us what
exactly the ICC has said what those
charges are and what that means in
practice for President Putin well the
the Russian leader and his child
children's rights commissioner are
accused of being allegedly responsible
for the abduction deportation of
children from Ukraine about which there
has been a lot of concern and
controversy throughout this conflict
thousands of children have been taken
from Ukraine and have been transported
sometimes through Crimea occupied Crimea
but then into Russia too often to faints
unknown so there are now arrest warrants
out for both of those individuals and if
they were able to straight if they were
ever too straight into countries who are
compliant with the ICC they would then
be liable to arrest now that's unlikely
to happen of course but it does
highlight the play light of these issue
of these children and the issue of the
controversy around their fate one
respected Human Rights group in America
has estimated that 6 000 Ukrainian
children have been deported to Russia
the ukrainians reckon it's more like
sixteen thousand the Russians themselves
have said since 2014 700 000 children
have been taken from Ukraine and I think
that that kind of gets the heart of of
this issue the Russians say they're
saving children from war from The Perils
of shell fire but also from the
nazi-controlled country uh the
ukrainians say they've just been taken
to be adopted by Russians but the older
ones to be put into military camps to
then fight in this war to be trained now
there's not enough evidence to to Bear
out exactly what is happening to them
but we can say that a lot of children
are going missing uh we uh personally in
December went to an orphanage in hairson
region where the director told us that
15 children have been taken by the
Russians soldiers had come in armored
vehicles and taken them to crime here
they have somehow managed to escape to
Georgia and we went there last week and
spoke to them they've had an
extraordinary Journey extraordinary
story which we can tell later but we're
able to get CCTV footage of Russian
soldiers going through this orphanage
which should be a place of sanctuary for
children looking for children exactly
why they're doing that is not clear now
the Russians say they're saving them but
I think the suspicion is it's more that
partly to help them demographically and
to bolster their troop numbers the older
ones but it's also for propaganda
reasons and we have seen Ukrainian
children and orphans being paraded at
events like the event in Moscow at the
stadium that Putin went to recently and
they're being paraded saying to the
Russian population so for domestic
consumption that we're saving these
children we're doing a good job out
there trying to bolster their claim that
they are effectively saving the
ukrainians for themselves
um it is a profound really troubling
aspect of this war isn't it what's been
happening with the children but it is a
relatively narrow charge relative to
what the ICC could have gone from what's
your read on on why this particular
aspect well I'm not a legal expert but I
think it is it is yes certainly
remarkable they have focused on this one
narrow I mean it's certainly a very high
profile issue and significant and has
drawn a lot of attention and controversy
and concern and I think if you're
looking at the plight of different
ukrainians the plight of children is
certainly the most emotional and
arguably the most important but I think
the suspicion is that the ICC and other
bodies are compiling evidence and
therefore they're going to present these
arrest warrants these indictments these
cases against the Russians
um as they feel they're in a position to
do so and they do appear to be confident
they have enough now at least to issue
arrest warrants against Putin and his
children's rights commissioner who I
have to stress is welcome the ICC saying
that she thinks it's great the ICC has
appreciated her work to help the
children of this country which which I
mean it's sounds completely
in that sort of response it's it sounds
it sounds back to front it sounds very
strange but a lot of the way we've seen
the Russians and their whole propaganda
War has been almost through the Looking
Glass in a sort of Alice in Wonderland
way what we see is abhorrent they are
presenting as an act of salvation of
helping the children and certainly
that's how she's presented her efforts
in Russian State media and that's how I
think it's they're probably being seen
by the majority of Russians all right uh
Dominic thank you very much indeed uh
Sean will be coming to you shortly so so
don't don't go anywhere we're awaiting a
response of course from number 10 to
these uh developments from the
international criminal court there has
been a response from the leader of the
opposition uh secure stammer who has
said I welcome the international
Criminal Court's decision to open War
crime cases against Vladimir Putin and
other senior Russian figures for their
barbaric actions in UK Ukraine today's
announcement sends an important message
there will be no hiding place for Putin
and his cronies and the world is
determined to make them pay for what
they've done I have seen firsthand the
destruction and Devastation waged on the
brave people of Ukraine these cases are
just the tip of the iceberg one day
Putin will face Justice until then the
focus of all who believe in Ukraine's
Liberty and freedom must continue to be
on ensuring her Victory well let's bring
in our U.S correspondent Mark Stone who
joins us now from Washington Mark as I
understand it we haven't had an official
response yet from the White House but
what is it likely to be
nothing official yet from the White
House incidentally I've just been
speaking to contacts up at the United
Nations
um there they are preparing a statement
I think as is the foreign secretary
James cleverly uh in London so I think
that hints at the um a slight surprise
with which um everyone has been taken uh
with this news not to say that that
there wasn't ex but it wasn't an
expectation that some sort of uh
criminal case against Vladimir Putin
would be brought at some stage um but
the form it would take and uh the uh and
precisely when it would come uh that
much was it wasn't entirely clear the
Americans um along with Europeans and
with the British have for for many many
months been compiling evidence at many
levels uh against uh Vladimir Putin uh
but but trying to join the dots to use
the phrase of one official I spoke to
recently
um from crimes that were committed on
the ground in Ukraine um butcher Urban
those are two two towns which have
become some Anonymous with such a
horrendous crimes against humanity which
is incidentally what the Americans
believe we are talking about in this
case
um nothing official yet but um President
Biden does have um what's known as an
ambassador at large for Global criminal
justice her name is Beth Van Shack and I
spoke to her a few few weeks ago and and
the first question I put to her was was
You Know How likely is it really that we
will see Vladimir Putin in the dock in a
courtroom
um is that really likely and she she
said it it that we should never rule it
out that this is all about a long game
and she pointed out that Augusto
Pinochet Slobodan milosevic these were
men who never thought that they would
see a courtroom and yet in time and it
took a long time they did she talked
about how this is this is about
deterrence apart from anything else if
you could be seen to pursue one person
and P people through his or her chain of
command and have successes either at
lower levels or indeed at the leader
themselves as they did with milosevic
and Pinochet then it deters so they hope
others from perhaps acting in the same
way she talked to about the um uh the
different Avenues and clearly the Avenue
that they have that is that is gaining
some ground is the international
criminal court but the domestic Pro
criminal justice system in Ukraine is
also pursuing crimes uh pursuing cases
as well uh the uh the Ukrainian leader
um what would like uh to pursue the
pursue the crime of aggression there are
complications with that the United
States is not wholly on board uh with
that particular Avenue not least because
they faced uh accusations of that 20
years ago exactly with the with the
invasion of Iraq a false equivalent so
say the Americans nevertheless the
Americans are not actually a signatory
of the ICC they don't believe that is a
problem they support it fully but
they're not a signatory itself
um one of the other things that really
struck me and we've discussed this
briefly already is is that the wealth of
evidence more than any other war in
history uh the there is so much evidence
that is being collated at many many
different levels and they are using that
whether it be CCTV uh photographs images
for from the news media like like this
but also uh in the palms of everyone's
hands every Ukrainian has a mobile phone
and they have documented uh crimes which
have been collated and are are being put
together to form this case against
Vladimir Putin and everyone in the chain
of command people will slip up and that
Ambassador van Shack said to me and we
when they do slip up when they cross
borders uh when they use aliases we will
find them she's just been in Ukraine and
was then in the Hague uh where where the
international criminal court is based
and so they're working together to try
and uh and bring um bring to Justice
those people responsible you'll remember
back in um uh at the time of Saddam
Hussein the Americans put together a
pack of cards of those who they believed
were responsible uh along with uh with
Saddam Hussein crimes in that country I
would imagine we will see images over
the course of the next few months of
individuals in the within the Russian
chain of command who they want to arrest
and at the top of that pack is Vladimir
Putin
yeah okay uh mark thank you very much
indeed we will of course bring you any
official uh response from the White
House as and when we get it President
Joe Biden is meeting uh with the Irish
Prime Minister Leo varanka this
afternoon uh let's uh bring in Now Toby
Cadman from the Hague he is an
international criminal and humanitarian
law specialist Mr Cameron thank you for
joining us on Sky News how significant
is this development
I think it's hugely significant
um we've known for some time that Karen
Khan the the prosecutor at the
international criminal court was
um investigating
um the the senior leadership uh the
Russian Federation
um and we heard several days ago uh
leaked information that warrants were
forthcoming
um I think it will come as a surprise to
some that he's gone right to the top uh
as far as Vladimir Putin is concerned
and certainly the the the charges that
are that are being brought on the basis
of this arrest warrant are hugely
significant
um and as we've already heard the the
numbers of children who were being
abducted and forcibly uh taken into into
Russia
um is is obviously makes the the case
hugely significant and actually makes it
an easier case to prove it's a it's a
fairly uh discreet uh charge
um and probably one where the evidence
leading up to Larry Britain is is is
very strong and and there may be
strategic reasons for why the prosecutor
has chosen this in particular yeah I was
just going to ask you at your view on
that uh is it
um that it's easier to prove because
this is a somewhat narrower charge than
perhaps the ICC might have gone for
absolutely and I what I would say is
that this is probably just the very tip
of the iceberg this is the this is the
start
um of course the what we've seen that
the the allegations coming out
previously that this is a state policy
that goes right to the very top uh
Vladimir Putin has has spoken himself
about these matters publicly in the past
um and you know quite often we we see
children being left out of the
international criminal justice process
and I think it is hugely significant to
to focus on this
um of course there are there are just a
a huge array of crimes that could be
charged
um and will be charged and as we've
already heard from the correspondent in
in Washington that we're not looking
just at the ICC there is also domestic
prosecutions and there is also the
possibility for uh the crime of
aggression to be prosecuted in a special
tribunal so I think this is very much
the start
um and it is it is a huge significant
step some reluctance though notably from
the United States as we were hearing
there from Mark Stone up for going after
the war crime of aggression might this
change things
well I think it probably will change
things of course there has been a
certain level of Discord between the
international criminal court and those
pushing for a special Nuremberg style
tribunal and and maybe this is a way
um to prevent
um that that being taken away from the
ICC I think there is some concern that
setting up a special tribunal
um would really sort of uh divert the
the uh the very necessary funding that
goes to the ICC and the very important
work that it's doing so it may well be
that this is also a strategic decision
taken by the prosecutor of the ICC
um
but of course there are there are real
complications with having a special
Tribunal for the crime of aggression
um what are the chances do you think of
President Putin ever facing Justice in
The Hague
well look I think we are we have to be
very realistic that we're not going to
see uh Putin in The Hague anytime soon
um and of course there'll be a lot of
cynicism as to whether we will ever see
him there uh of course we won't be
looking at a trial In Absentia at the
ICC and of course the
um other state parties who who in whose
territory he may he may enter have a
responsibility to hand him over to the
ICC but as we've seen with the El Bashir
case in in Sudan who was indicted for
genocide and still has not been handed
over
um there are very real problems with
with that and of course an individual a
political figure like Vladimir Putin is
going to be so much more problematic
than al-Bashir in Sudan and so so I
think that there is going to be a great
deal of fear and reluctance if he is to
enter but it may well be that it
prevents him from actually leaving
Russia and that in itself should not be
insignificant it has a huge impact and
of course
Justice is measured in in many many
different ways and and the fact that
they have issued the arrest warrant and
are proceeding to charge him is
significant enough in itself
do you think that internally
um very difficult as you're saying there
for him to leave Russia internally it it
weakens his grip on power
this is this is sort of a further
in the armor
um of what we have have been seeing
increasingly over the last few weeks
um both internally and externally of
course the position that they're they're
taking now is is a good position of
strength they're saying that they don't
recognize the ICC
um and of course his Minister who's also
a subject to the response as well is
welcoming I'm sure they do not welcome
it but this this is not what what they
wanted they they repeatedly say the OCC
has no jurisdiction over Uh Russian
citizens it does because of the
situation in Ukraine and it may well be
just going back to the the charges that
Khan has chosen these charges in
particular because it's a crime that
occurs on two states Ukraine and Russia
and as the ICC has ruled in previous
cases it has the jurisdiction for those
crimes of forced deportation so it's an
easier one jurisdictionally as well as
evidentially to to bring
Toby Cadman a really good of you to give
us your analysis on Sky News thank you
very much
well let's uh bring you this now from
the United Nations in New York or in the
last few minutes the Secretary General
spokesperson has been asked about this
news that the ICC has issued an arrest
warrant for President Vladimir Putin as
we've said many times before here at the
international criminal court is
independent of the Secretariat uh we are
we do not comment on their um on their
actions but does it have any impact in
the way the UN
operates with regard to the president of
Russia for example if President Putin
wanted to visit any un headquarters
whether it was in Geneva Vienna New York
would he be permitted to enter will the
Secretary General still talk or meet
with President Putin I I don't want to
answer
hypothetical uh questions because as you
know issues of travel involve involve
others uh we will continue as a general
rule the Secretary General will speak to
whomever he needs to speak in order to
deal with the issues out in front of him
does he though fear that this is a
threat to diplomacy because President
Putin is clearly the person who started
the war in Ukraine one might assume that
you need President Putin to bring the
war to an end one can't see or I can't
see President Putin being allowed to
come by the host country the U.S to the
U.N General Assembly high level week I
can't see how you could foresee another
Summit between President Biden and
President Putin as we saw in Geneva is
this a threat this arrest warrant to the
diplomacy that you're working so hard as
I said and this is this applies across
the board the Secretary General will
always speak to whomever he needs to
speak to in order to advance our lots of
other people won't be able to speak I
can only I can only speak for him deji
and then Joe let's just speak for let me
let you uh you can just speak for
Secretary General on this uh since the
ICC has issued the warrants for for uh
President Putin will will this affect
his the secret generous decision to meet
or to talk with Mr Putin is that I mean
as I said to James as a rule of thumb
across the board
secretary's General will speak to
whomever they need to speak to to
advance uh the issues
that are on their desks regardless
there's the warrant or not
Joe and then Pam
there's been a response from the foreign
secretary James cleverley has tweeted
those responsible for horrific war
crimes in Ukraine must be brought to
Justice we welcome the step taken by the
independent ICC to hold those at the top
of the Russian regime including Vladimir
Putin to account work must continue to
investigate the atrocities committed
let's bring in our International Affairs
editor Dominic wagon also retired Air
Vice Marshall
um Sean Bell uh Dominic to you first of
all hearing that question there in the
U.N is finally balanced isn't there many
people saying that Russia should be
kicked out they shouldn't have a seat on
Security Council but it is it is an
arena of diplomacy yeah and um I think
you know they were saying the
spokesperson there slightly caught on
the Hop standing by the surprise
choosing his words carefully but being
asked about what I think the question
that a lot of us are asking already what
does this mean for the the peace process
if there is one the the hope for a
negotiated end to this war because if he
isn't indicted or criminal war criminal
how can Vladimir Putin fly somewhere to
discuss and negotiate the end of the
conflict it does make it more
complicated it makes it more complicated
also for countries like Kazakhstan where
James cleverley has just landed where he
has tweeted from a country that has
abstained in votes on this issue this
war twice now because it's close to
Russia now I think Under Pressure
countries like Kazakhstan to work out on
whose side they really are can they
continue hedging their bets when the
leader of Russia is what could be an
indicted war criminal so it makes it
more complicated for them and I think it
certainly makes it more complicated for
the UN but also for any Diplomat who's
hoping to give Lana Putin a an off-ramp
as it's going to happen I was just going
to bring in Sean there and it
complicates matters for bringing an end
to the war it does massively whilst this
is a significant development from the
West perspective I do Wonder from
Putin's perspective whether there's
anything more than a minor speed bump
he's got a decision to make his invasion
has not gone well he's stalled he's
getting his Nation on a war footing his
industry on War fitting his people but
he probably was facing a an imminent
decision about whether you negotiate to
at least pause the war it's very hard to
see that this decision will help that
happen and Putin almost certainly has a
date with Destiny he walks in the
shadows of the piece of the great uh and
it's very difficult to see how this is
going to stop him okay gentlemen thank
you very much for your analysis so
you're watching Sky News stay with us
coming up in the next hour more on the
breaking news that the international
criminal court has issued an arrest
warrant for Vladimir Putin
[Music]
thank you
It's Five O'Clock you're watching the
NewsHour I'm Simon Morrison coming up in
the next 60 Minutes the international
criminal court issues an arrest warrant
for Vladimir Putin accusing the Russian
president of committing war crimes in
Ukraine the international criminal court
has issued two warrants of arrest in the
Eucharist situation
for Vladimir Putin president of the
Russian Federation and foreign
authorities hail it as an historic step
on a long road to Justice
also ahead summer holidays under threat
as unions warn of significant delays to
renewals as passport staff announced
five weeks of strikes
hundreds of people are arrested in
France during protests against Plans to
raise the retirement age there
and Paris Hilton tells Sky News of her
experiences in America's controversial
camps for troubled teens it was almost
like they enjoyed abusing children and
every day I was just praying that I
would wake up from this nightmare
[Music]
good evening we begin with breaking news
and the international criminal court has
issued an arrest warrant for the Russian
President Vladimir Putin the court was a
has accused Mr Putin of war crimes
including the unlawful deportation of
children from Ukraine to Russia or
Moscow says the decision has no
significance whatsoever with Ukrainian
authorities calling it just the
beginning well here's what the head of
the international criminal court had to
say
the international criminal court has
issued two warrants of arrest in the
Eucharist situation
for Vladimir Putin president of the
Russian Federation and foreign
commissioner of the Russian president
from children's right for the alleged
war crimes of deportation of children
from Ukrainian occupied territories into
the Russia Federation
it is forbidden by international law for
occupied powers to transfer civilians
from the territory they live in to other
territories children enjoy special
protection under the Geneva Convention
the contents of the worlds are secret in
order to protect victims the ICC
attaches great importance to the
protection of victims especially
children
nevertheless the judges of The Chamber
are dealing with this case decided to
make the existence of the world's public
in the entrance of justice and to
prevent the commission of future crimes
this is an important moment in the
process of Justice before the ICC the
judges have reviewed the information and
evidence submitted by the prosecutor and
determined that there are credible
allegations against these persons for
the alleged crimes
the ICC is doing its part of work
as a court of law the judges issued
arrest warrants the execution depends on
International cooperation
well the Kremlin has responded to the
ICC decision calling it null and void
and in a statement the Russian foreign
Ministry spokesman Maria zaharova said
the decisions of the international
criminal court have no meaning for our
country including from a legal point of
view Russia is not a party to the Rome
statute of the international criminal
court and bears no obligations under it
or meanwhile Ukraine has welcomed the
decision with the chief of the
presidential staff saying it's only the
beginning Ukraine's prosecutor General
Andre costen said this is a historic
decision for Ukraine and the entire
international law system today's
decision is a historic step but it is
only the beginning of the long road to
restore Justice
well in the last few minutes the foreign
secretary James cleverley has tweeted
his response those responsible for
horrific war crimes in Ukraine's Ukraine
must be brought to Justice we welcome
the step taken by the independent ICC to
hold those at the top of the Russian
regime including Vladimir Putin to
account work must continue to
investigate the atrocities committed
well International Affairs that it's a
Dominic waghorn is in the studio with me
now
um so of course welcomed by Ukraine
which has also been conducting their own
independent investigation Dominic but
interesting responses from the Kremlin
not not just from the foreign Ministry
which we spoke of there but uh the
children's commissioner very much a
response that fits Russia's narrative
yes so the ICC has issued arrest
warrants for two people Vladimir Putin
but also his children's rights
commissioner Maria lavova Bulova who is
a controversial figure she claims to
have adopted and saved in her words 22
Ukrainian orphans including a 15 year
old boy who Russian State tv aired an
interview with and in a piece where
Maria lavova bolova was seen to be
weeping with joy as she put it at the
opportunity been given to to save these
children so she is seen by people
outside Russia and particularly by
ukrainians is responsible for the the
systematic efforts to abduct and Deport
Ukrainian children she's presenting as
an effort to save them and this is her
response to what's happened to her she
says in response to the ICC arrest
warrant it is great that the
International Community has appreciated
this work to help the children of our
country that we don't leave them in war
zones that we take them out that we
create good conditions for them that we
surround them with loving caring people
so she is seeing this as a badge of
honor the fact that she has now been
named in this arrest warrant and that
the ICC wants to put her on trial for
alleged crimes war crimes to do with the
Abduction of children it just shows you
the kind of Through the Looking Glass
glass topsy-turvy way that the Russians
have portrayed this war throughout on
any number of issues they have taken
they have sent soldiers into orphanages
that we've been to in Ukraine that we
have CCTV footage of looking for for
children to take them and abduct them we
interviewed some children last week in
Georgia
um who told us that they refused to go
and when they refused to go the Russians
fired guns into the air so they were
forcibly put on transports into Crimea
and sent into Russia and so we have
testimony and the ICC clearly has a lot
more of it that shows that this has been
a systematic forcible attempt to remove
children against their own will whereas
the Russians are presenting it as as an
effort to to save these children and
connecting it directly to Vladimir Putin
as well yes and that's what's remarkable
about this I think and it makes it um
all the more surprising I think the time
is interesting as well I don't think the
timing's related to this but obviously
next week Xi Jinping China's president
is going to Moscow to meet with Vladimir
Putin it makes it more difficult for him
I think it's more Awkward for him now
that he's going to be sitting down with
a man who has an international war
crimes arrest warrant out for him the
Chinese are not part of the ICC they
haven't subscribed to the treaty for
various reasons they don't they object
to the concept of extratorial
jurisprudence but they have cooperated
with ICC and they certainly have been in
touch with its authorities so it'll be
very interesting to see how they react
to this extraordinary development in
this war yeah and the UK of course just
calling on China to try and negotiate a
peace till Dominic thanks very much
indeed for now
um well let's bring in our chief
correspondent Stuart Ramsey he's in
tonight Pro in Ukraine for us and a U.S
correspondent Mark Stone in Washington
D.C Stuart let's come to you first
um uh how are people in Ukraine reacting
to this you have covered this war since
the beginning and of course witnessed
some of those war crimes that people
speak of
yeah I mean president zelinski has been
going to the ICC since the beginning of
the year saying there are lots of war
crimes that need to be investigated here
and there are in fact being investigated
here including uh the Abduction of
children
um people here will obviously be very
pleased uh that the ICC has made this
decision
um though I think they're probably all
pretty realistic that it's not going to
change very much in the short term but
the ICC has shown in the past it is
prepared to take its time and as long as
it takes to bring people to trial but it
is a big story here and it is a very big
issue I've talking to an ngos telling me
that in the last year or so they
estimate that 16 000 children were taken
from here to Russian territory but the
figure is incredible when you go back to
2014 if you take all the years since
this uh Russian affectionate Invasion
began they say as many as 700 000
children have actually been taken away
to Russian territory and many of them
have not come back now I was
interviewing a 15 year old girl the
other day who went to a summer camp
um and uh that's how it was sold to her
in a family she says when she got there
it was clear it wasn't the case they had
to sing the Russian national anthem they
weren't allowed to have the yellow and
blue colors of Ukraine in their bedrooms
and they were told they weren't going
home now her mum traveled about 8 000
kilometers to come and get her and she
did go to Crimea and got her out what
was interesting well many interesting
points in our interview but what was
interesting she said when they they were
left
she joined over a hundred buses with 30
to 40 children on each just on her trip
that headed to Russian territory so it
sort of shows the scale of the movement
of children and that's why President
Putin and others uh that's what they're
being accused of it is as I say an
extremely uh big issue people are very
upset about it here and but I think they
will be pleased that at least these sort
of steps have taken place today
specifically with those children but as
I say there's an awful lot of more
allegations of war crimes here than just
that
exactly Stuart Ramsey for now thanks
very much indeed let's take you straight
over to the United States and our
correspondent Mark Stone who is there
now Markham no official word yet from uh
Washington and President Biden but um
the U.S does have an ambassador at large
four Global criminal justice and
Ambassador Beth Van Shack is the sixth
one she came into her position just
after this War began and you've been
speaking to her recently
yes I spoke to her a few a few weeks ago
around the time of the the anniversary
of the invasion and uh since uh we spoke
she has been to Ukraine uh itself she
spent a few days there um seeing
firsthand the evidence that is being
collected on the ground uh in towns like
Butcher and urban uh where uh so many
war crimes as the Americans now
categorize them have been committed
she's also been uh to the Hague as well
where she would have met officials from
the ICC
um her office have told me in the last
few minutes that they're preparing a
statement but they are they're clearly
pleased with this this was always one of
several avenues that that the state
Department's Global criminal justice
department has been has been pursuing uh
the ICC being being as I say one of
several Avenues uh the domestic judicial
process in Ukraine is another Avenue uh
president zielinski is also as we've
been discussing I've been trying to
issue a a case against the of the crime
of aggression the act of the invasion
itself is a crime and from that uh the
the other war crimes uh have been
committed so argues president zielinski
that is another Avenue it's slightly
more complicated
um certainly from an American
perspective but it's something that that
they do uh broadly support uh as well
um there has been a statement uh the
only one so far from Lindsey Graham a
very senior senator on Capitol Hill uh
one-time chair of the of the Justice
committee on on Capitol Hill as well
I'll read a bit of it to you it says the
decision by the ICC to issue an arrest
warrant for Vladimir Putin is a giant
step in the right direction for the
International Community it is it is more
than justified by the evidence to
forgive and forget Putin's war crimes
that are occurring on an industrial
scale would damage the rule of law
law-based rule of the law-based world or
um order established at the end of world
or two um so that's the words there of
Senator Lindsay Graham and I imagine
that that will be
uh mirrored by on both sides of the
aisle here on on Capitol Hill
um President Biden who's meeting the
t-shock uh today is is I would expect
we'll we'll make some sort of statement
at some point uh uh the the key question
that I put to uh Ambassador van Shack
when we spoke a few weeks ago I said
that you know many will see it as
inconceivable that Vladimir Putin could
literally be in the dock uh could see
his day or could have his day in court
and I said you know how important is it
to pursue Justice however unlikely it
would be she disagreed with the premise
of my question she doesn't think it is
it is inconceivable that this man could
appear in in a courtroom she pointed uh
to history uh Slobodan milosevic uh
Augusto Pinochet uh his and habre of
Chad these are all men who who thought
that they had escaped justice but they
face Justice yet against that others did
not
um president Assad of Syria that is
still in power in Syria despite the war
crimes that he has committed so there
are huge huge challenges and they're
then under no illusions that it will be
easy but they do believe uh that it's a
long game uh it's a game of deterrence
as well to pursue one person deters
others either in another country or down
that the chain of command within Putin's
um regime it deters them from from war
crimes too so it's it's a long game it's
about joining the dots and eventually I
imagine it will this is the beginning
there will not just be this charge
related to Children very emotive against
Putin but many other charges and it will
not just be Putin but a chain of people
right the way down to to soldiers on the
ground in Ukraine Russian soldiers on
the ground in Ukraine they will slip up
Ambassador Ambassador van Shack said to
me they will part across borders they
will use aliases if we know what they
look like we will get them eventually
phone in Washington DC thank you